you do stand-up so much this doesn't
happen to me that much because the times
that I go out and it's it's more of a
because I'm here oh I love when you do
them but I don't get I don't get a
second - I don't see the same people
over and over again do you ever find
that you see familiar faces see people
that you know in the audience sometimes
like if you go to Boston it's like oh
you're from Boston you see someone you
know there's a guy named Sam I see in
San Francisco all the time he's gonna be
happy when he doesn't see this I don't
know I said doesn't see maybe you will
say yeah I'll send it to him sure he's
got a lot of friends
ma yeah here's your here's your edit
point yeah sometimes that does happen
we're gonna keep that in so so you look
like a dick in ability here's your edit
point
I like that Andy always looks like Matt
Damon deep in character right with the
glasses that what movie is that those
are Damon frames oh yeah yeah the CIA
one yeah yeah I can't remember the name
who shot the good shepherd that guy wins
nothing we have nothing to give you
you'll get this plant on the plant is
not a real value now I sometimes I do
shows and I don't know that there's
someone of note in the audience right
I was recently in Boston in Cambridge
there's a play a great place called the
comedy studio mm-hmm where I started and
I was doing stand-up and I was watching
the show before I went on I was going on
last and there were these two hot women
young women in the front that the whole
show were whispering like it was the
word it's worse than heckling they were
going like this right right right
every comedian what at Black Mirror
nightmare to be doing stand-up and
there's two attractive girls which is
what made every nerd into a comedian
right in the front row whispering and
laughing people went stage but in the
bad way
yeah so nobody's mentioning him and then
I go on last and I just I tell a joke
and they're whispering and laughing and
giggling and I'm just like what's going
on what I can see you they were they
were in the front row they were in the
light like the spotlight was on them as
well and I just go what's going on I can
see you please stop tell another joke
they keep doing it right right then I'm
like can you please cut it out please
cut it out then I get a little bit more
like shut up
I'm a front look at my face I'm here to
help but you know you push pity too far
I'm like please check the yeah at a
certain point I take the curtain and I
go I don't care enjoy the show however
you want I just don't want to see you
and I cover them with the curtain clown
I thought this would get a big laugh
right nothing the whole audience turns
on me I'm like what is going on after
the show I find out it was Obama's
daughter
[Applause]
[Music]
she looked great
terrible kotti comedy audience Odin
that's a treat whoever do you think who
let you put curtain around President
Obama's daughter that's what I'm saying
why weren't you Shh I should have been
shot you see the shot I've never got
enough saging than like why wasn't i
shot at least the little laser beam like
you're trying to entertain a cat on my
face I covered them I was like shut up
shut up shut up
you should vanish and I covered them
with a thing and the Secret Service was
like I like this guy
[Applause]